bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
mot sur rt france kai eide est donc le
premier chef d'état reçu par le
président macron depuis la levée du
confinement
c'est pour lui son premier voyage en
europe et choisit donc la france est-ce
qu'il faut y voir un message
oui oui un message pour apaiser les
relations bilatérales entre les deux
pays
et puis sans doute aussi pour se
concerter à propos de la crise libyenne
frontalière de la tunisie qui est
inquiète de cette instabilité chronique
et également pour tenter de prouver
auprès de la france un allié pour un
pays qui est dans une situation
financière très très difficile comme
vient de le montrer votre reportage à
tataouine
il faut réchauffer aujourd'hui les
relations bilatérales pour quelles
raisons rappelez-nous est ce qu'elle se
sont rafraîchies ces dernières semaines
il ya il ya eu cette fameuse ce fameux
débat au à la rp un l'assemblée des
représentants du peuple
l'assemblée nationale tunisienne qui
demandaient à la france des excuses pour
les crimes commis durant la période
coloniale
donc il ya eu des moments de tension tht
et situation un peu compliquée il n'a
pas vu que de presse d'artprice saïd
centre de son silence pour rappeler que
c'était lui qui fixait le cap en matière
de diplomatie de politique étrangère et
non pas au président du parlement
puisque le débat avait été initiée par
le présent du parlement qui est l'un des
partis ennahdha qui joue un rôle
aujourd'hui très important dans la
tunisie nouvelle depuis la chute de ben
ali
vous aimiez qu'elle vous évoquer la
situation économique de la tunisie qui
est très impacté aussi par la crise
parce qu'elle est sous traitants de
l'aéronautique et du secteur automobile
français emmanuel macron pourrait faire
des annonces débloquer des aides on le
rappelle la france est le premier
partenaire économique de la tunisie
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre comme
déclaration ce soir des déclarations
mais surtout des des actes
on peut imaginer que la france viendra
apporter
en tout cas les tunisiens l'espère
vivement une aide massive sur le plan
financier parce que la crise tunisienne
est aujourd'hui amplifiée par la
pandémie du coït 19 et on vient encore
une fois je le souligne parce que les
manifestations de jeunes dans ce pays
sont fréquentes
elles sont importantes et puis ça
l'immigration clandestine
tous sont aujourd'hui énormément les
jeunes tunisiens qui n'ont aucune
perspective et peu d'avenir dans leur
pays et qu'ils préfèrent tenter de s'en
remettre à une hypothétique vive
meilleur de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée ce qui fait que la
situation sociale est aussi très
compliqué c'est qu'avec ce qu vide
on sait qu'il y aura aujourd'hui très
peu de touristes européens qui viendront
dans ce pays alors qu'en moyenne il ya
entre 6 ou 7 millions de de touristes
donc c'est un manque à gagner est
extrêmement important pour les caisses
de l'état tunisien et pour compenser
cette cette situation devrait aussi être
abordé ce soir là la question libyenne
commun la tunisie se positionne dans ce
dossier la position traditionnelle de la
tunisie est celle d'un pays qui veut
jouer la neutralité
ça c'est le premier élément le deuxième
élément c'est d'un pays légitimiste
puisque les nations unies reconnaissent
uniquement le gouvernement du premier
ministre failli à sa rage basée à
tripoli ce qui est également le cas de
la france dans les focales de souligner
même si la france a soutenu également le
maréchal à retard la tunisie est très
inquiète de cette instabilité chronique
est du pays qui s'enfonce de la libye
qui s'enfonce dans une guerre civile qui
ne veut pas dire son nom mais qui est
une réalité
et puis la libye a été également pendant
de très nombreuses années une soupape de
sécurité sur le plan social économique
puisqu'il y avait des centres des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
tunisiens qui vivaient et travaillaient
en libye qui est un pays pétrolier
extrêmement riche du temps de kadhafi en
tout cas et cela a permis à la tunisie
de d'avoir une relative stabilité sur le
plan social puisqu'il y avait cette
soupape de sécurité pour les tunisiens
qui pourrait trouver là des débouchés
professionnels et économiques
merci beaucoup qu'aider reim je rappelle
que vous êtes à directeur de recherche à
l'institut de prospective et sécurité en
europe professeur à sciences po